bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale la
leçon aujourd'hui la défense sicilienne
bien entendu mais surtout la variante
chef d'un gang variante la plus tendue
de la cécilienne ouverte ou en tout cas
il devrait manquer plus classique et
pour analyser cette ouverture totalement
super g avec moi stéphane laborde
bonjour stéphane bons joueurs loi alors
comme c'est la première fois que tu
viens pour la ccil ndash dorff et bien
tu l'as déjà nous dire ce que tu en
penses de cette fameuse ccid ndash
d'ordre mais très difficile à jouer très
difficile à jouer parce que les noirs
manque d' espaces quand même c'est pas
facile à trouver mais kasparov a
démontré que c est l arme la plus
tranchante à son avis également fisher
et fisher aussi évidemment fischer casse
kasparov les deux champions du monde et
on peut noter que une des plus belles
parties qui ait jamais été joués c'est
une sicilienne un âge d'or c'était une
partie à notre fischer espace qui lors
des championnats du monde des marins du
poids ou des pions empoisonné parions
que vous avez vu avec jean-luc chabanon
malades à l'ouverture un petit peu pour
voir ça sedan prend b2 fantastique où
les blancs dans un pion pour se
retrouver avec une très grosse attaque
c'est la variante la plus compliquée de
la ccn d'âge d'or c'est le cloisonné
bien entendu il ya eu également d'autres
parties des tic notamment la plus belle
partie garry kasparov ai jamais joué de
sa vie c'est la partie karpov et
kasparov 24e partie du match les sports
sont obligés de gagner il est noir c'est
très très tendue ambiance super chaude à
sa vie à séville et joue tour sept ou
huit manoeuvre destructrice évidemment
il ya beaucoup de grands classiques dans
cette défense nador la vente chef d'un
gang donc ça va être tout de suite quoi
dire de plus que de vous montrer et bien
exactement les coûts constitutive de
cette variante alors c'est pas la
variante la plus à la mode actuellement
donc tout à fait tout à fait mais elle
est quand même elle a quand même été
extrêmement joué notamment lors des
matches
karpov et kasparov alors là
exceptionnellement l'échiquier tournée
côté noir
tout simplement parce que nous vous
proposons de jouer la cécilienne âge
d'or avec les noirs et que donc on va
prendre le bon côté pour nous c'est
normal il faut tout de suite s'habituer
à voir les bonnes couleurs du bon côté
eux quatre ces cinq cavaliers f3 donc ça
on l'a dit la cécile anne ouverte
stéphane ça commence par kiev 3 quoi
qu'il arrive puisque on va jouer des 4
et échanger des pièces est probablement
le cool plus
if d'autres coûts sont quand même moins
moins fort et permettent aux noirs de
s'en sortir assez facilement des six
tout ça pour de la neige d'or c'est le
fameux coup souple des 4 puis on prend
des quatre cavaliers prend des quatre
cavaliers f6 qu'elle et ses trois à six
donc si vous voulez des commentaires sur
ces coups là vous allez dans l'émission
initiation à la neige d'or et vous aurez
tout ce qu'il vous faut
assises c'est le coup stéphane qui
caractérise complètement sa défense âge
d'or moi tout à fait avec des idées
notamment de jouer b5 et surtout de
prendre la classe b 500 poches des fonds
de cinq échecs se cache un cavalier
d'aller sur cette case aussi ça peut
souvent être embêtant parce qu'on veut
souvent développées saddam sur la casse
et sept coups très utile et en même
temps coûte très très souple puisqu'on
n'a pas encore bougé le pion eux on l'a
pas mini-hand aussi ce niveau 5
et ça c'est avantageux pour quoi et bien
parce que le foot est vite contrôle
encore la case gk donc ça évite que les
blancs puisse pousser tout de suite
gedo g4 et commencer à venir taquiner le
cavalier m6 en jouant une attaque
d'options donc c'est un coup très simple
fous eux deux ça c'est un petit coup il
n'a pas l'air très très fort et les
blancs tout de suite annoncent leur
ambition de jouer avec le petit run away
ils veulent très vite joué petit rock et
l'idée c'est de jouer f2f 4 la poussée
du pion pour essayer de mettre sous
pression le centre en noir tout à fait
donc faux de ce n'est pas la variante la
plus tranchant mais c'est un des coups
qui débute la varende chef d'un gang on
va voir que là donc on peut jouer avec
les noirs soit 26,65 c'est-à-dire
conception sont aussi son lot 5 puisque
là il est temps de l'avancé mais nous
avons choisi nous avons sélectionné pour
vous le coup de 7,6 et prenons le
meilleur donc là on arrive pour la
première fois stéphane dans la structure
de pions dite du petit centre
oui petit centre caractérisée par les
deux pions aussi celle des six qui
contrôle très bien toutes les cases
devant f5 des 5,5 et c5 dont qui empêche
les blancs d'avancé plus ça fait une
espèce de murailles déjà donc les noirs
ont un avantage de structures d'options
puisqu'ils sont plus nombreux au centre
ils ont deux pions contre un seul pour
les blancs les idées dans ce petit
centre stéphane elles sont de plusieurs
ordres
on peut jouer soit avec eux 5 assez
souvent chasser le cavalier provoquer
une réaction soit avec des 5
donc de toutes façons les noirs ont
beaucoup trou soit ne pas bouger du tout
au centre c'est toutes les options alors
que les blancs eux leur plan d'attaqué
contre ce petit centre sont très connus
il faut qu'il joue avec l'option f en f4
il installe donc un duo de pions en 4 f4
ensuite il je sois aux cinq soit f5 au
choix s'ils peuvent
voilà les deux plans d'attac communément
admis mais les noirs eux quand ils ne
bougent pas leur centre ils menacent de
jouer avec des cinq très souvent donc
ici attendent ceux prévus dit donc c'est
une partie d'exemple à un an contre
kasparov
ce premier jour le coût à 2 à 4 c'est
très logique qu'avec des c6 donc là on a
dit énormément dans introduction à la
nage dorff que lecavalier on savait
jamais trop ce qui fait le même temps
c'est si souvent 17
oui parce qu'en 17 souvent il peut aller
sur la case c5 faire pression sur le
pion à 4 tout à fait donc c'est là aussi
un plan intéressant mais ici le problème
stéphane si on veut gagner sur les 15 17
et bien tout simplement on n'a pas le
temps d'attaquer plus rus/kat
efficacement puisque les blancs vont
jouer avec f4 et dès que le cavaliere a
lancé cinq y aura eu cinq et on va se
faire attaquer très très méchamment
donc il faut pas permettre ça on joue
donc à laisser 6 et on va voir quel est
le plan petit rock biologique normal et
des convois petit rock quand on est en
train de lacer siden il faut penser à
une chose il faut penser aux options de
ces deux bons ces corneilles qui est
mentionné ça quand les blancs ne joue
pas convoque le pion c2 est faible et
toujours les noirs auront énormément de
jeux dessus mais le contre jeunes aura
effectivement se joue sur la colonne ces
semi ouverte
on voit que cette colonne une tour peut
l'occuper efficacement effectivement
pilonné le pion ces deux voire parfois
se sacrifier contre l'usc avait laissé
trois faire un sacrifice de qualité
c'est ça puisque quand on prend qui a
laissé trois bien aux principes suivants
4 donc ça c'est plusieurs idées fausses
est tout à fait logique foule 3 c'est
normal petit rock et maintenant les
banques jouent le coup f2f quatre
caractéristiques tout à fait ils veulent
justement faire des menaces soit avec f5
soit avec eux 5
pour l'instant le 5 n'est pas possible
puisque contrôlé par les noirs mais en
tout cas on sait jamais ça peut arriver
plus vite qu'on ne le pense
dams et 7 faut calmer le jeu il faut
empêcher blanc de menacer un jour aux
4,5
voilà sept damas et sept contrôles eux
cinq derrière le pion des six voilà ça
fait
bonnes possibilités de contre attaque et
en plus ça sort de la colonne des sas
est un thème important aussi parce que
les blancs vont être amenés à occuper la
colonne semi ouverte dès avec une tour
est menacée ou 4,5 donc la dame a
intérêt à sortir de cette colonne et en
plus stéphane sa connecte les tours
enfin pas tout de suite mais ça a
tendance à permettre mais le temps de se
connecter à une connexion de tours ce
qui est toujours une bonne chose dans
des objectifs de l'ouverture et après le
11e coude et blanc rouge la france hong
kong et sérieux en jachère pourquoi
secoue le petit ce petit coup de roanne
un coin mystérieux oui et non alors on
va expliquer pourquoi dans ce genre de
position les noirs ont une menace
directe
ils menacent de jouer cavalier prend des
quatre fous prend des quatre le pion à
vent sur la case aux 5
on va montrer par exemple sur un coup
comme h2 h3 qui ne sert à rien par
exemple ça c'est un exemple on prendrait
en d4 fou prend des quatre ou cinq donc
en toute logique
puis on prend nos cinq moyens pourraient
prendre vous reculez le fou ont reculé
le fou ça amènera une autre un autre
type de plaisir qu'on verra position
tout à fait pion prend foule 3 et
maintenant les noirs pourra jouer ou c5
et chargeant les fous échangeant les
footeux cases noires et ça c'est très
important pour eux oui parce que le
fouet deux se retrouvent être en mauvais
choix maintenant parce qu'il tape sur le
pion aux quatre exactement gars il va
avoir du mal à trouver des bonnes
diagonale et dans ce genre de position
les blancs aimerait bien de temps en
temps pour voir je me fous g5 ou alors
pouvoir quitter la diagonale avec le fou
mais là ils peuvent pas mais là ils
peuvent pas puisqu'ils sont cloués donc
de toutes façons le courroux à agen à sa
logique
ça évite la menace des noirs qui est de
prendre des cats et de joie là et ça
évite ultérieure échec
imaginons si le fouet trois quitte sa
diagonale un coup comme d'hab décidant
des six échecs prendrait le plan b de
points là tout à fait donc c'est un coup
de sécurité très classique extrêmement
jouer et qui nous amène à notre position
les noirs ici doivent choisir un coup le
coup qu'on vous conseille c'est tour
huit coups effectivement cette fois-ci
stéphane très très mystérieux mais comme
on a vu dans beaucoup beaucoup de cas
les noirs jouent avec le 5
hélas la tour envie de trouver un poste
très intéressant puisqu'elle va taper
sur le court no 4 après l'ouverture
après échange de quelques pièces dans
cette position donc nous sommes au 11e
où les noirs viennent de jouer court
vite
il ya beaucoup d'ordre de coûts qui
amène à cette position c'est vraiment
ici davantage chez belin
comme on dit tout à fait alors là les
blancs plusieurs possibilités notamment
il ya des plans de base de dames 1
davos est d'amener la dame sur la 4g 3
essayer de monter une attaque contre le
roi noir quand l'om et angers 3 ans
menace aux cinq ans menace aussi aux
cinq essais pour soutenir l'avancé de
4,5 et parfois je crois que les blancs
jouent aussi frustrant fait froid c'est
le coût principal
ça c'est un coût qui n'est pas un coup
d' attaque mais un coup d'anticipation
du développement des noirs sadi au noir
et bien vas-y développe toi maintenant
si tu peux le faire en tout cas tu vas
avoir du mal à bouger ton pions by
passel fou s'est mis dans cette grande
diagonale
donc il ya plusieurs coups dit adam un
pour venir en g3 et jouer avec eux cinq
là où vous annonce les plans des blancs
parce que c'est ceux contre lesquels
vous aux réalités fouet f3 qui est un
coup pour vous dire comment vous
développez également le ku'damm d2 qui
est un coup que je n'ai pas compris qui
est un coût de développement naturel
mais qui est difficile à expliquer
puisqu'on ne voit pas vraiment walid et
des blancs enfin on va quand même le
commenter dernier coup c'est fou j'ai un
qui est un coup curieux et qui permettra
justement de voir exactement comment les
noirs doivent réagir si les blancs ne
font rien alors là c'est un homme
qu'elle est blanc canton kasparov et
choisit le coup ben je choisis le
ku'damm des voeux mystérieux donne des
deux assez mystérieux et parce que là ça
fait rien contre l'attack du rock ça
fait rien pour contrôler le centre est
par contre salies les tours c'est lille
et tours celle avantage très clairement
les tours sont maintenant interconnectés
on peut en mettre la table par exemple
sur la case de 1 ou sur la case d1 voilà
tout à fait donc c'est un coût de
développement mais il est très difficile
pour les blancs data question aux six c1
ceux qui ont des six parce qu'il est
très très bien défendue par le fawcett
qui ne risque pas de quitter son poste
donc ça c'est une remarque donc d'un des
deux camps vous ne comprenez pas eh bien
vous jouez un peu naturel fou 17 qu'on
ne développe pas normal l'idée de ce fou
fou 17 céline et ours affronte h2k et
alicia keys
ça protège de caisse et si c'est à dire
qu'on reprend avec le fou ans et fixe le
prochain coup ça peut être tour à des 8
si les blancs ne font rien de très
menaçant on envisage également de jouer
cac et prend des 4 es fou c'est 6
donc ça c'est également une possibilité
même des deux n'est pas un coup très
dangereux ça ne me fait rien on peut
tout simplement se contenter que le foot
est cet octroi d un tournant il termine
son développement mais sa tour sur la
colonne semi ouverte et on l'a vu il va
avoir du mal à créer des menaces sur le
plan des
d'autant plus que garry kasparov dans
cette pétition jouent tour à des mythes
et maintenant que fait wisches manhattan
annoncé bien c'est très très difficile à
dire puisque on ne voit pas comment il
peut améliorer la force de ses pièces
c'est à dire que s'il joue un coup comme
g4 qui on le verrait d'un coup
thématiques avec l'idée tout et g5 et
bien ce moment-là garry kasparov il
prend en d4 et surtout prend eh bien il
joue fous ces six libérant la caisse 17
pour le cavalier ou même cinq ou même au
sein des seins qui conclue entre
attaques sur le plan on peut voir cette
variante d'ailleurs imaginer angers 4
cas la primature et pouvant rapidement
que cavalier prendre des quatre faut
prendre et 4 e 5 a l'air fort puisque
ces attaques le fou et en même temps le
défi le pion g4 à l'air perdu oui tout à
fait ce qui est fou et cavani attaque
c'est le genre de position dont il faut
se méfier stéphane puisque même contre
la corruption g4 on est encore exposés à
l attaque
mais ici tout simplement donc là vous
vérifierez par vous même comment ça se
passe mais a priori la salaire plutôt
bien pour les noirs donc ici après tour
à des beats anand a joué cavalier b3 et
là on va vous montrer juste un seul coup
pour les noirs dans cette position posez
vous la question qu'est ce que je vais
faire maintenant
et là il faut comprendre que le problème
c'est ce fou 17 qu'on a envie de le
mettre sur la grande île ionale mais
qu'on n'a pas envie de dépasser notre
cas les c6 donc pour ça vous trouvez le
coup fou c'est vite la menace c b6 est
fou bessette et une fois que les noirs
ont mille fois sur la grande diagonale
dans une structure de petits centres et
bien ils n'ont plus du tout à
s'inquiéter donc la partie a continué le
forez 3b 6 dan f21 amende
il tente tout de suite une attaque
directe à takara ça c'est dangereux
puisque ça attaque le pion v6 et sa
maladresse à ramages ça tourne à 8
derrière mais s'il ya eu tout simplement
qu'elle les 17 et la position s'est
simplifié très vite puisque après qu'un
des quatre fous bessette
les noirs ont achevé leur développement
les blancs n'ont strictement rien fait
pour cette position il n'y a pas d'
attaque particulière donc là vous avez
une très bonne position
on va maintenant stéphane passé à notre
deuxième exemple way qui est donc la
partie talent kasparov
on va arriver directement à la position
qui nous intéresse c'est à dire cette
variante chez fnac proprement dit ou là
à nantes avait joué dam des deux coups
qu'on n'avait pas compris ah non vous
avez joué dam des deux ici
ou de talent beaucoup plus intéressant
c'est le coude à me voilà canardo riait
mais c'est un petit coup de dames
intéressant parce qu'en fait on veut
traverser transféré par dont la dame sur
la case g3 menaçant aux cinq oui mais
menaçant aussi le roi noir menaçant la
sent peut-être f5 et vous assisterez six
attaquants on assemble des choses
donc là il faut réagir tout de suite il
ya une vente précise il faut la
connaître tout simplement on prend en d4
fou prend aux 5 réactions totalement
thématique un iphone si le foot doit
partir si le fou vient par exemple sur
la 4g 1
on prend un f4 la tour prend et on joue
au cices on verra ce sera le thème d'une
partie qui viendra après et la très très
bonne position
tu reprends restric tions progrès 5
s'il faut s'en va c'est toujours pareil
on a encore poussé 5 way qui va être pas
mal
ou alors faut aussi ce bref on a une
position normale l'idée du coude a
besoin c'est de jouer dans cette
pression d'alger 3 pas mal parce que le
pion à 5 est clouée sur cinq est cloué
je ne peux pas prendre le fou parce que
la dame serait en prison
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur le
clouage d'ailleurs vous allez dans le
tableau de diagonale de son vous cliquez
sur une technique et stratégique les
bases il ya une leçon spécialement
dédiée au cloud est donc ici c'est un
clouage de base le pion aux cinq écuries
est attaqué autre problème stéphane en
est loué le pion g7
ouais donc le cavadee m6 se retrouve
également au paysage assez le fou 120
donc si le fou vient la fuite ou si le
fauve ans et 5
oui c'est une erreur puisque dans ce cas
là il faudra tout reprendre si ce qui
finira tout à fait donc je fous des 8
force est donc maintenant la dame et
protéger nos rites les noirs menace de
prendre le foot ou les la tour e 8
protège depuis 1,5 et le food évite
continuer de protéger le kayak 6 donc
c'est un coup idéal coup tout à fait
tout à fait bien pas idéal stephen parce
qu'ils les patrons en train de
construire
mais techniquement totalement juste fou
au 3 mai les plans sont obligés de
partir vous aussi ce important de juifs
ou aux six maintenant puisque les blancs
pouvaient menacer cavaliers 5 t et
dessins attaquant la dame qui était pas
forcément très agréable
tours a des seins et là on se découpe en
3 h 8 et maintenant qu'est ce qui se
passe sur lequel des cinq et bien c'est
fait non je vous prends des simples mais
surtout on prend ta dam j'apprends
d'options ces deux ouais ce fameux
fiancé 2 on en a déjà parlé ici talent
fou j'ai ça
ils menacent donc éventuellement de
prendre un f6 et après la reprise du fou
jouer tous les deux sur la 4g 4 qui
échangent encore les fougasses blanchet
qui cette fois-ci s'installera en d5
donc ça c'est l'idée thématique de des
blancs ouais mais là des sports ajouté
vegemite et pas de problème mais
reithalle revient d'espagne revient et
répétition des compétitions et donc ce
coup finalement d'amour n'est pas très
dangereux il faut réagir très
précisément parce qu'elle va les prendre
cavani prend fou prend de 5.5 réaction
classique
voilà donc les blancs a perdu un petit
peu un terrain gendarmes inquiets quand
même un de courant pas ça d'un coup un
peu lent oui et ça permet au noir de
justifier le fait d'avoir joué le pur
noir deux fois au 6 e 5 exactement
exactement d'autant plus que ce qu au 6
e 5 est très naturel puisqu'il permet de
développer le fou ces mythes qui est
toujours un de nos problèmes de
développement parties suivantes stéphane
marty suivante
voilà la partie mirosiichenko contre
roubles exquis alors là c'est un essai
tout à fait curieux on va revenir un
petit peu en avance c'est dans cette
position là hop
si les noirs s'il est blanc essaie de
jouer le coup à 5,1 essayant de fixer
les pions noirs avant que kevin soit
réellement c'est assez pour empêcher
définitivement les noirs d'avoir des
idées de jouer b6 ou des 5 pour mettre
leurs fours sur la case 17 tout à fait
donc là dans cette position au showcase
et six attaques le pion à saint cloud
qu'elle est bête noire c'est l'idée
maintenant la menace c'est fou aux trois
et on vient s'installer sur les cases v6
avec cavani à 4 également salars forts
salaires très fort mais donc on joue les
cinq tout simplement les cinq maintenant
si les blancs ne prennent pas en passant
est bien menaces b4 éprise du pion de
quatre prisons passé obligatoire d'aprr
en échec au roi et chaque mois d'où
l'intérêt d'avoir joué en l1 avant oui
en ce cas là on peut pas et issifou
bessette développement terminé alors
salaires idéal pour les noirs parce que
les blancs peuvent plus jouer sous les
300 et la dame contrôler la casse et ils
ont réussi à mettre leurs fous sur la
case baisse est tout à fait maintenant
les plans ça va être très très simple on
va jouer cahier des quatre attaques
l'option ces deux on va me menacer on va
centraliser nos tours on va jouer pour
effriter tour des mythes ou tombé huit
tours des mythes on a beaucoup de cases
ici donc tout simplement pour expliquer
que ce coût à 5 n'est pas dangereux
puisque nokia c6 attaque le pion qui
avait 3 et des 5 donc c'est un tout
petit exemple juste pour dire que bon il
faut faire attention quand même mais ce
n'était pas un vrai danger
nouvel exemple attendre contre kasparov
une autre partie position de base donc
on se rappelle que hollande avait déjà
joué dam des deux que talent avait tenté
dames 1
ouais mais ici à nantes joue le coup le
plus classique dans cette position c'est
le coup fait froid phase iii avec l'idée
de mettre la pression sur toutes les
pièces là qui sont sur la diagonale et
le carré lisse et 6 le fou le plan b 7
et la torah 8 exactement l'avantagent de
secours ou f3 c'est que stéphane dans
cette pression les noirs ne peuvent pas
jouer b6 ça serait une grosse faute qui
perdrait très très vite après les procès
sa perte comme matériel d'un prompt et
de 5,5 à bléharies couvert points et
l'enfilade et attaque le cabinet sis ils
attaquent lequel vient pas répondre par
des cinq qui fermerait la diagonale on
peut jouer qu'à des cinq médias qui
avaient les rangs des cinq qui on prend
et fou prend des cinq karma cela pour
les problèmes sont intactes donc après x
3 on ne peut pas jouer ce coup b6 sais
pas s'il faut pas se tromper
faut pas se tromper comment faut-il
jouer c'est une question qu'on peut se
poser donc il ya eu tourbe et 8 qui a
été joué les noirs ne sachant pas trop
quoi faire
mais la vérité est ailleurs il faut
jouer dans cette position fou 17 la
menace donc c'est une fois de plus
cavalier prompt fou prend et aux cinq
puisque le fou vient danser 6 très
avantageusement donc sur n'importe quel
coût de dames on prend des quatre on
joue au 5 et ensuite on jouera avec fous
ces 6 il faut contrôler la case des 5
avec le fou c'est très très important
donc ça c'est le principe de base dans
cette position très logique qu'avec des
3 calais b 3 ça évite les menaces
justement qui était qualifié par là ça
peut menacer à 5
ça peut vous nas et ça peut menacer à 5
puisque à 5 ça fixe les pierres noires
et fourbe et 6 vient qui est très fort
foulée si ce qui arrive
ça serait pas une très bonne nouvelle
donc dans cette position on joue le
groupe des six pour empêcher assez pour
empêcher à 5
maintenant les blancs toujours ils
peuvent rien faire s'il ne joue qu'avec
les pièces donc ils sont obligé
d'arriver au plan critique le plan qui
doit vous faire peur c'est l'avancée du
pion j'ai donc il joue g4 d'autant plus
que l'ici la benâte g5 et très forte
puisque ça devienne une pièce voilà et
alors c - 6 - affaiblissant que qu'on
l'a vu tout à l'heure puisque maintenant
le foot est roi et la dame d'un protège
bien g4 et en plus le force 3 pour
revenir angers 2-1 éventuellement trop
bien protégé son droit
donc les blancs ce fait glisser un peu
le rock mais pas trop d'autant plus que
la dernière fois stéphane il y avait eu
cinq qui attaquaient le cahier des
carnets mais là c'est pas possible ça
n'attaque pas et donc je sens que perdre
très vite après f5 switcher 500 kg 5
black john très fort donc là il faut
avoir les nerfs solides
donc je vous fous ces huit dans cette
position maintenant c'est possible
puisqu'il plus cavalli processes donc on
est revenu dans la position d'avant ont
effectivement perdu d'autant mais l'idée
stéphane c'est qu'on va compléter notre
développement a cofondé cette très
important et en même temps va rapatrier
qu'ils avaient sur la case 17 mois ça
libérerait une place pour le cavalier
donc j'ai 5 voilà qu'elle allait
desservir la célèbre comprend le coût
foncier vite
le cavalier pour revenir sur la case des
sept fous j'ai deux pour passer la dame
en attaque où est passée la dame en
attaque
ces petits malins ça libère aussi la
tour f1 williams qui prend le contrôle
viennent maintenant le kiosque a très
peu main à cf 5-fu bessette les noirs
ils ont complété leur développement
maintenant il faut juste ne pas se ferme
était alors là faut faire attention pour
les blancs les blues pourraient jouer
vouloir jouer f5
mais ça ça va faiblir le roi blanc c'est
à dire que la sur f5
on peut supposer que les noirs prendrait
un fcm probablement peut-être et jouer
ensuite cavalli ses 625 alors prendre 25
ces problématiques stéphane puisqu'il y
aurait quatre de ses cinq ans et
charisme et en revanche la réaction
normale sur le coup f5 c'est de jouer
cavalier 17 sur la case au sein de kayak
on n'a pas peur d'eux f6 puisqu il faut
en fuite donc voilà comment on réagit
sur cinq c'est à dire que le coup et
cinq est un énorme affaiblissement
puisque ça donne complètement la case
aux cinq au noir donc en général on
n'est pas tout à fait chaud pour le
jouet clément dame h5 menace très simple
tous rêvent trois tours h3 et mat
donc ici il faut réagir enfin kelly b 4
pour l'instant on contre attaque
sanctions ces deux tours f2 donc sur la
bonne voie mais alors si on joue ton
rêve 2 évidemment on abandonne l'idée
torres 3 à 3 3 oui tout à fait mais
surtout à droite de toute façon en fait
il n'y a vait g6 qui joue et quand même
ici puisque c'est le plan de défense
damas 3 est maintenant un plan
thématique fois fluide donc j'ai six est
un excellent coup de défense dès que
vous êtes attaqué il faut jouer g6
repasser le fou éventuellement g7 avec
une position solide ce fou n'est pas là
pour les prendre en c3 on veut pas faire
cette menace l'ordre juste consolidé la
position autour de nos trois dans cette
position des clés pour jouer avec f5
on jouera cabello 5 et on va tenir là on
est évidemment stéphane dans la position
la plus compliquée qui existent de seul
devant cech no way c'est celle où les
bleus ont poussé tous leurs pions ils
ont défendu ce côté là avec leurs pièces
et donc ils obtiennent une à des
perspectives d' attaque assez forte
là il faut avoir les nerfs solides et
ces tensions de position que kasparov
avait joué contre karpov tour cette
suite tours 8
et ensuite percé le 5 avec l'ouverture
des lignes très compliqué donc voilà on
va revoir cette variante tranquillement
roi h 1 tour 8
ça c'est le début foued 3 le coup le
plus dangereux
il faudrait fou 17 on ne peut pas jouer
b6 à cause de quelques pensées site et
sur calais b 3 puisqu'on a menacé de
prendre des cats et 2,5
bonjour b6 avec l'idée de repasser le
fou sur les 15 17
j'ai quatre fous ces 8 g 5
quelle est cette fougue et deux pour
passer la dame fou bessette on a terminé
le développement maintenant il faut se
défendre
damages 5 bonjour québec a tracé
kasparov il a tout calculé tour f2 g6
damage trois fois fuite
la position devient extrêmement
compliqué évidemment c'est très très
difficile
dernière partie dernier exemple
c'est cette partie c'est une partie de
moi en fait que j'ai joué
donc à pékin contre un maître chinois yu
chen zhu xiao zheng donc dans cette
partie évidemment j'ai joué ce que je
vous conseille donc tour vite il a joué
fou g11 coups apparemment anodin on se
demande un petit peu ce qu'il veut faire
et là la bonne réponse c'est de jouer
cabinet prend des 4 donc ça oblige le
pouvoir en jouer encore en forme alors
là il a pris de la dame
s'il pointe du fou c'était pareil ouais
tu apprends des 4 e 5
donc ça tout à fait normal ce qui est
très important quand on affaiblit à
capter 5 c'est d'être sûr de pouvoir le
jouer il faut aussi autrefois aussi
c'est de prendre des 5 avec la dame des
trois pions prend 1,4 donc là s'il fait
qu'ils avaient des 5
j'échange dans des 5 on n' ya pas de
problème puisque j'ai un tout petit déjà
pour preuve quatre fois au cices et là
quand vous avez cette structure dont il
faut aussi ces qualifs 6 qui défendent
la caisse des singles vous n'êtes pas en
danger surtout que dès que le cas libyen
là on le prend un peu fou donc ensuite
ça va tour à f1 oui parce que sa bouche
la taxe sur le plan des six exactement
hélas le dernier petit coup ses
cavaliers 17 coups tranquille sur calais
des cinq on prend toujours il peut pas
reprendre de la dame comme il le
voudrait puisque l'option seydoux est en
prise aux menaces de ce week end 5 qui
attaquent adam et qui va défendre le
curé vii très bien et ensuite on va
jouer avec g6 fuite
donc ça tout ça ça c'est vraiment la
position de base élémentaire que vous
devez connaître toujours il faut
vérifier donc par exemple après coup
j'ai un cavalier prend des quatre ou
cinq échanges des pions et fou au cices
voilà ça c'est vraiment la manoeuvre que
qui doit devenir chez vous une seconde
nature comprend qu'il prend delà de la
dame ou du fond c'est un réflexe de la
main
ouais exactement eu cinq dames bouge
surprend f4 tourcoing f4 faut aussi s
est ensuite qu'il ya des sept radios 5g
six fours et fuite
tout ça ça doit se développer
naturellement donc stéphane je crois
qu'on a fait à peu près tout de cette
défense yens lundi
ouais on a vu les plus grandes lignes
les plus intéressantes c'est surtout
cette variante avec france 3 qu'elle put
en charge tout à fait c'est la variante
choisie par allende à noter que kasparov
n'a jamais perdu dans cette position ou
en tout cas sauf une fois contre sokolov
mais c'était extrême il a fait une gaffe
alors qu'il était gagnant donc la
position est saine puisque quatre portes
n'a jamais perdu
ça veut dire qu'il n'ya pas de problème
soyez en confiance et entraînez-vous
éventuellement vous pouvez essayer la
position de base
on vous l'a déjà montré ses selles après
tour vite beaucoup d'essais pour les
blancs beaucoup de réponses pour les
noirs c'est vraiment thématique donc
position à jouer en famille on te dira
en famille exactement
bon alors vous remercie d'avoir suivi
cette émission merci stéphane d'être
revenu donner un petit coup de main
ouais mais je suis toujours là toujours
là et donc on vous donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour toujours la
défense naldo enfin thème qui vous sera
communiquée très prochainement merci